but thanks to the organizers for
inviting us to speak here today our
name's Mike Craig and I'm a machine
learning scientist at G Tian Qi Tian is
a startup based in here based here in
London and we apply we kind of combined
methods from quantum chemistry and
quantum physics with the newest machine
learning algorithms in order to improve
the drug discovery process everyone that
that works works there was kind of like
gave everyone has a basic research
background and we have people from
quantum physics from machine learning
biochemistry my background is really
kind of between the machine learning and
biochemistry so that's where I'll focus
the talk today I'll start by just
talking to you a bit about some of the
the models that were that we're using I
talked about it specifically about Graff
convolutional neural networks then I'll
go into some of the open source tools
that we use that in some of the open
source datasets do a quick demo and then
show some preliminary results on the
toxicology data set that they were
working on for a little while so I'll
start with just the obligatory deep
learning slide that all machine learning
talks tend to have so the deep learning
can be applied to many different data
domains but it's a really specific
specifically very good with image
recognition so these data sets like I'm
an ist
looking at handwritten digits and also a
image recognition with image net
convolutional neural networks have been
shown to perform very well on these
kinds of datasets natural language
processing with recurrent neural
networks as well and when combined with
a Monte Carlo tree decision algorithms
you can play games at them even but one
similarity that all of these datasets
have at least the two-dimensional ones
is that they all work on regular grids
so the kind of basics of how this
convolutional neural network works is
that they all operate on regular grids
and and update based on the pixel values
so say to say you want to to kind of
stack a bunch of these convolutional
layers on top of each other and feed in
images of faces
at the most shallow layers of the
convolutional neural network you're
going to have relatively simple features
being extracted and that's kind of the
the basics of how Vysya networks you're
trying to extract these hierarchical
feature representations and as you get
deeper into the network the features
become more complicated so again at
these shallow layers you have basic
features like edges shading curves
things like this as you get deeper you
have slightly more complicated features
being extracted like no in the case of
faces you'll have something like noses
or ears eyes things like that and as you
get deeper you have more complete
looking faces or features in this case
these terrifying little ghost faces that
are at the deepest portions of the
neural network but the the issue of
these is that many real-life datasets
are not organized on these regular grids
so it's been research over the past few
years
aimed at trying to generalize
convolutional neural networks to work
with data that's based on modeling the
data as a graph and in the simplest
sense of graph is just a pairwise
relationship between objects and kind of
simple examples of these are social
networks where you might have nodes
being individuals and edges being some
kind of relationship between those two
people road maps are a good example of
something you can model as a graph
various biological networks like brain
networks and protein interaction
networks are often modeled as graphs and
what's most relevant to us or our
molecules so these kind of
representations of molecules are often
depicted as graphs so so the the goal of
what we're trying to do is try to
generalize these kind of basic
convolutions to work on molecular graphs
and with with the standard convolutional
Network you can see that you're kind of
sliding this of taking the window and
siding across the image so that you're
looking at every portion of the input
image and you're extracting these
hierarchical features from from the
image with a graph you're doing
something slightly different so you're
going to to each node in the graph and
you're combining information from its
neighboring nodes
and that's kind of the equivalent of a
convolution in in a graph sense as you
go deeper in into the graph
convolutional Network you start the
combining information from a lot larger
and larger neighborhood around that that
node in literature this is referred to
as message passing so the people have
started calling these a message passing
neural networks here's just an example
of how you can kind of model a molecule
as a graph and then as an adjacency
matrix the way we actually use these
graph convolutional languages we have
two different inputs for them so we have
the adjacency matrix for the molecule
and also a feature matrix and this
feature matrix contains a feature vector
associated with each of the nodes in the
in the graph
an important point to make here is that
you can create many different adjacency
matrices from the same graph so there's
actually a summing function at the end
of the after the final layer which makes
the D model invariant to permutation of
node labeling which makes it slightly
different from a standard convolutional
Network this would be the kind of most
basic layer propagation rule you could
construct with this which is already
somewhat powerful and here you just have
your weight matrix and a nonlinear
activation function like a real ooh the
sound of two two problems with this this
propagation rule the first is that
multiplication with a means that you're
summing if features from adjacent nodes
but not from the node itself so the
simple solution you have there is just
adding the identity matrix to the
adjacency matrix which forces it to some
note some features from the node that
you're applying the convolution to the
second issue is that a is not normalized
meaning that multiplication can lead to
scale changes with the the feature
vectors and in this sense if you have a
very highly connected graphs so if you
individual notes of a very high degree
Vixen result in these very large changes
in scale for our purposes this isn't a
very big issue because atoms can't
really have and degree higher than four
but when you're looking at social
networks or biological networks these in
a very high degree for individual nodes
so applying a symmetric normalization
the degree matrix
allows you to normalize that and take
care of that so this is the actual final
layer propagation rule you you end up
with I'm just to give a somewhat cartoon
example of actually how this how this
works so if you take a very simple graph
like this year and you want to apply
this this rule to this node in black
each one of these nodes has a feature
vector associated with it each H
neighboring node and what you're doing
is is summing or combining all the
feature vectors from those nodes from
from the adjacent nodes and also from
from the node itself so that that's just
a kind of an illustration of how it
works this is some some just kind of
tensor flow a very simple cartoon code
just to show you the different pieces of
one of these networks and to show you
how we how you can put this layer a
propagation rule in so first you just
stand shading your tensors and your your
wave matrix right here is the the actual
layer propagation rule so this equation
that were applying down here where we're
calculating loss and optimizing and
finally just just training the data or
trick training the model rather it's
just kind of a very simple example of
how a house could use how this could be
used and it's important to point out
that if you can get your data into a
format into a graphical format then it's
um it's relatively easy to apply these
these kinds of convolutional networks to
it there's a lot of open source software
on github that allows you to do that
pretty easily to kind of just do like
this you know step through all of these
uh yeah the actual like processing the
information so so you're starting with
just modeling your molecule as a graph
and this case your atoms are the nodes
and the bonds between the atoms are
edges at each layer you're passing
messages between adjacent nodes and as
you get deeper into the the network the
the larger the neighborhood gets so
you're sharing information across
eventually the entire molecular graph
that's after the final convolutional
layer your the feature vectors are
summed across all of the atoms and this
makes the the model invariant
a permutation of node labels this is an
important point just because in standard
convolutional network what you'll
typically see donnas people will input
rotated images to try to infer this
rotational invariance for features but
you can't really do the same thing with
with graphs you can't just real able all
of the nodes at you know how many times
you want and create a new adjacency
matrices and use these as input because
this is the kind of an endless process
and what end up working so this is
something we have to deal with this
permutation invariants the node labels
to transition a little bit we talk more
broadly about the difference open source
tools we have available to you in drug
discovery if you're interested in
looking into this field one of them is
this Rd kit so Rd kid is a chemo
informatics toolbox that's in Python and
C++ this can give you you know basic
chemical information and also allows you
to easily work with chemical data in in
Python so there's just a load of
functions that allow you to manipulate
chemical or molecules in different ways
and get certain molecular properties
from them as well and then there's these
two very large databases that that we
use as well the first is a Kemble this
is specifically for drugs and drug like
molecules and this contains about 1.4
million compounds in this case 1.4
million molecules and I think several
thousand different targets for those
molecules so this could be anything from
how well it binds to a particular ion
receptor or how soluble it is or
something like this all these different
measures associated with the molecules
and a pubchem is a bit more general this
is much larger as about 96 million
compounds in it but it's not specific to
to drug like molecules so if you're
interested in material science or other
areas like that you can find molecules
in there to curate those molecules we
use this database filtering tool 9 which
allows you to actually extract
information from these databases and
this is where having an organic chemist
on the team is really useful because
they can direct you towards what kinds
of questions are interesting and what
kinds of assays can be used to ask
certain questions so combining nine with
pubchem and then some domain knowledge
allows us to to curate these databases
and specific ways to ask specific
questions about various molecules and
most relevant for this talk is this tool
called deep camp so this is a developed
at Stanford and it's an open source deep
learning platform for a chemistry
generally and it's also it's really
geared toward drug discovery and this is
everything from basic data loading
functions provides lots of data sets
that are contained within Campbell very
easy way to just interface with that
pre-processing tools and also a lot of
the graph convolutional models different
versions of graph models and a lot of
wrappers for scikit-learn as well so you
can use psych it models in this pretty
easily to I mean lots of evaluation
functions and things like this CDM is a
really useful tool for us so now I'll
show you a little bit of deep cam to
show you we like kind of how easy it is
if you want to get start and actually
see how to run one of these models in
deep cam so I'm here this is just
loading a bunch of stuff this is the
actual data set that we're loading here
there we go ye-yeah here's the actual
data set that we're loading see if that
work
there
and here's the the loading of this data
set down here we're just defining a
metric so what we're trying to do with
this data since this data set provides
solubility measures so this is how well
particular molecule can can dissolve
into water essentially and what we want
to do is predict how how well it can do
that and this is very relevant for drug
discovery and that you want to make sure
that your molecule will dissolve well in
blood and various things and what we do
is just call it correlate these these
two measures so correlate our predictive
value with the real value and just take
the r-squared lie down here we're
defining our actual model so this graph
column tensor graph I'll show you a
little bit kind of like the guts of it
and how it works in a second and he were
fitting
so I'll let that run for a second and
show you how it works so this is the
actual implementation of graph comp in
deep Cam's is a bit more complicated
than the one I showed you previously so
up here you're defining your your atom
feature vectors and your adjacency
matrix and there's also some atom
indexing functions as well which is
really just to make these more
computationally efficient this is just
kind of specifics of how to have a deep
networks itself and he down here is the
actual body of the graph convolutional
network so you can see each graph
convolutional layer here batch
normalization pooling layers things too
in this yeah and then there's this
readout graph gather function at the end
is what's something across all of the
all of the actual notes after the last
competition of layer so we'll see I've
already made it yeah so we have a
training actually of 0.95 for training
our CR square root of point 95 and a
validation of 0.8 for and test of 0.88
so so that DPN will split the data for
you in various ways too which is a very
convenient you can apply a lot of
different splits do it to make the
problem harder easier depending on what
you're trying to do and here's here's
just the values correlated with each
other so so predicted so real on the
x-axis and predicted on the Y so so
there's a very high correlation but and
this is the test data set this is
approaching state-of-the-art do various
kinds of hyper parameter optimization or
changing around how the actually the
actual model that you're using to you
can improve this but this is just you
know completely you know vanilla
implementation of it
so so yeah now I'll talk a bit about the
another problem that we're working on so
this is another data set called tox 21
and this is a large data set of
molecules and various toxicity measures
so what it was it's really important
that early stages and drug development
that you are testing to make sure the
novel molecules you're generating are
not toxic so one of the the assays in
this data set is an ion channel in your
heart so if you have a high binding
affinity with a particular drug you're
trying to develop with this ion then
you're really developing a poison so you
want to make sure you stop that at a
very early stage of development and
there's a lot of effort that goes into
screening out these molecules at these
early stages in this this data set was a
result of the collaboration between
several large scientific organizations
that pull together all of this data that
they have about the toxicity of various
molecules and the goal is really to get
away from toxicology screening and
experimental studies and animal models
and such in towards a more computation
with an automated approach yeah and
again this various this particular
dataset contains 12 different assays
each with a binding affinity for a
particular receptor another point to
make here too is something called
multitask learning this is another tool
that deep chem provides for you it
allows you to train the same model using
many different data sets and essentially
it allows you to to kind of leverage
certain assays that have a large amount
of data and they can help improve
results on assays that have say a
smaller amount of data or something like
this
and this is particularly useful in
domains like like this where access to
data is quite difficult and in finding
large databases as is rather difficult
so so anything you do to squeeze up a
few extra points is definitely something
worth doing and DPM also provides a
simple wrapper for this to allow you to
use it with a scikit-learn models as
well so to show you basic results we we
have four that so
we use the extra boost as a baseline
model so this is a tree ensemble method
which performs relatively well on these
tasks out of the box so I'm just showing
a rock curves for three of the v-12
tasks here and showing results down here
for a graph comps this is again the same
kind of very simple implementation of
graph comedy you can see just based on
the a you see that you get a lot more
power out of these graph convolutional
networks as opposed to the tree based
methods CS so to sum it up I mean
there's there's many different
applications of machine learning and
drug discovery it's like an endless
number of areas where this can be
applied to and I think looking at graph
convolutional neural networks in
particular is really interesting and
modeling molecules as graphs is an
interesting approach to feature izing
datasets and there's access to a huge
amount of this data online and also many
of these open source packages in Python
finally just want to mention very
briefly that we're hiring a head of
machine learning hiring a head of
research engineering right now to work
with all these fine people and if you're
interested in you can come see me vit or
Lawrence I think is here as well to talk
about that thank you very much for your
time
[Applause]
we have time for a couple of questions
yeah that's something that's something
that we're working on all the time so
there's a using Bayesian optimization
approaches is one thing we've done in
the past which seems to work relatively
well also currently we're explaining
hyper band the hybrid algorithm I think
was released last year so trying to use
all the tools we can to optimize the
high parameters in this automated way so
that's our approach
yeah yeah so there's a work by Thomas
kids and Max willing but from the
University of Amsterdam I think they had
a recent paper and I clr about this
applying attention to two graphs oh yeah
I think I don't know I haven't read the
paper or anything but I know it's an
area of interest definitely
that's a good question I I'm not sure
but yeah possibly have to talk to one of
the chemists about thank you for the
talk I've got a question about gradient
boosting in one of the last slides so
you mentioned that the number of degrees
of freedom is limited so I'm just
wondering is the decision tree
how will you just describe the decision
trees it's more dboys it more white in
your case so I think we use 500 trees
for this but I'm not sure actually [ __ ]
but yeah I mean we have an optimized
site parameters or anything for extra
boost in as much as much detail as
graphical so there could be definitely
something worth exploring them
I was just gonna ask if you strip out
the final layer in the neural net and
now we have some sort of embedding of
your grafts do you have any insights
into what happens in that space as you
kind of move around in terms of chemical
property server-side that's very
interesting question - yeah not entirely
sure but yeah so I mean the the yeah I
mean maybe we could talk to the chemists
or fist is here
to larger molecules so depends on what
kind of network einde of data you have
so so it protein interaction networks
are kind of different from from this
kind of a like modeling an individual
molecule but I know there was some work
at Stanford that looks specifically at
protein interaction networks and
applying these methods to to them so
yeah I think they're very admirable
well this question
well this tank Michael
[Applause]